you have to have trusting teams you have
to have a worthy rival you have to have
a capacity for existential flexibility
and you have to have the courage to lead
so just cause we have to give our people
something to advance a cause so just
that they would be willing to sacrifice
their interests in order to do so in
other words turn down a better paying
job or frequent business trips or
working late hours and though I may not
like those things I do them because it
feels worth it because I believe in what
I'm a part of here because I feel that
I'm helping Advance because there's no
achieving in the infinite game the goal
is not final achievement the goal is
advancing to progress in the infinite
game and to have that vision of an
idealized state of the world all men are
created equal right it's an ideal that a
nation is striving towards that will
never actually get there but will die
trying that's the point and we can offer
people the same thing inside an
organization in fact we have to um to
give them something to advance now how
is this different from the why a why
comes from the past it is an origin
story every single one of us has our own
unique why it is our Birthright it comes
from the sum total of how we were raised
as kids it is objective you have one and
you have one for the rest of your life
the only one right and the rest of our
lives are about making the decisions
that help us uh keep in balance with our
why a just cause doesn't come from the
past it just causes about the future
it's about where we're going right
um you can have multiple just causes you
can have one professionally you can have
one personally you can have one for your
family you can have one for your church
and we're involved in all of these
there's massive pressure put on people
especially young people too what's your
vision well we're not all Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates we're not all Visionaries we
don't have to have a vision but we do
have to find a vision that we can find
someone else's vision and we are so
compelled by it that we want to make it
our own that's what it means to go work
for a company with a Visionary leader
that we believe in that Vision so
clearly that we take their vision and we
make it our own and we will happily
contribute our work our effort in order
to advance what is now my vision right
Martin Luther King had a vision he stood
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial and
told us his vision but his vision became
our vision so I may not have come up
with that Vision but I found it and I'd
like to devote time and energy to help
Advance it even Beyond him we have to
give our people a just cause
we have to have trusting teams your
vision comes from your purpose and your
purpose comes from your pain when people
ask me all the time how do I find my
purpose how do I find my one of the
number one questions people have well
it's actually pretty easy to find your
purpose you just have to understand that
it comes from your pain whatever you
struggled with the most as a human being
in your life is the thing that you want
to help other people through and that
may be something on a big scale where
you want to change the world and make
sure that it never happens to anybody
else ever again and ease the suffering
for others along the journey if you're
watching this video you're on this
channel it's probably more the way that
you lean but it could also just be the
people closest to you the closest
members in your family that your closest
friends the the team that you're on your
co-workers those are the people who you
want to help the most you don't have to
go off and change the world but you do
have to feel like what you do matters at
the end of the day all of us want to
make sure that we wake up and we feel
like today is going to matter
when you feel like today matters to
somebody that you're going to be doing
work that is unservice to other people
that you will matter to them that what
you create today will matter to them
it's going to make you feel better it's
going to make you feel alive it's going
to make you feel worthy it's going to
make you feel proud of yourself however
when you wake up and you feel like today
doesn't matter like nobody cares if you
show up that your work will be
meaningless you're just going to toil
away and do useless things we probably
all had jobs like that right if you had
a job like that you woke up you went to
your work felt like you're just gonna
plug away even if you were working hard
but it just didn't matter there's no
appreciation the work either did matter
it didn't matter if you showed up or not
but that's I think most people we've at
least had a job like that at some point
in our past and that's the path down to
feeling worthless and depression anxiety
and suicide a lot of the problems that
we're facing a lot of for for a lot of
people the biggest problem is just you
don't feel like the work you're doing is
meaning anything to anybody and and
therefore you feel like you don't matter
because because the work you're doing is
not meaning anything to other people
therefore you don't matter because deep
down we all want to serve you were built
to serve we all want to feel like what
we do matters so you don't have to
necessarily have a big vision for the
world but you do have to figure out your
purpose
when your purpose comes from your pain
so for me I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
as a 19 year old getting this first
business off the ground and turning down
the big jobs and failing and sucking and
making no money and just pouring
everything I had into this company and
being absolutely broke
financially and and emotionally you know
the initial high of I'm going to start a
business I'm going to be an entrepreneur
we're going to do this we're going to
change the world yeah uh was great and
then it wears off when you realize
nothing is happening we're barely
getting any customers we're barely
making any money the the the the high of
the launch Fades pretty quickly and then
you're in the muck of actually just
trying to create things and I really
struggled and those were the worst days
of my life
um it led to some of the best days uh
but just the worst days emotionally
feeling like I was worthless
and so that's why I do what I do
because I want to help all the 19 year
old Evans out there not struggle as much
as I struggled not be as embarrassed to
ask for help not to be as ashamed to
feel like a total failure not to feel
like I'm going through this alone not to
have zero mentors and building this up
not to pretend like everything is great
when it's not
and it's not only talking to 19 year
olds around the world you know it could
be you it could be a 52 year old woman
you know it was going through the same
thing it's that emotion and so I love
helping I love helping a lot of big
people with their channels and their
businesses but uh my heart is really in
the startup because that's where I
really struggled the most myself
and so that's what I'm trying to create
and every day wake up and and try to do
something else whether it's a YouTube
video or a tick tock or an Instagram or
write the book or speaking engagement
and whatever the next thing is VR Evan
and hologram Evan and 3D Evan and
whatever beaming into your living room
this is something forever when people
ask me how do you how have you not burnt
out how have you how do you keep going
so many years later thousands of videos
later
well I I feel like I'm living my purpose
it's another I record videos on Tuesday
it's another Tuesday sitting here in the
car and my wife is at her acupuncture
appointment and I'm I joined her and I'm
I've got my coffee and I'm sitting in
the car making videos and this is video
number I don't know how many thousand
and why keep going well because I feel
like this video will mean something to
at least one person
maybe it hits a million people maybe it
hits one person but it's going to be
valuable to at least one person and when
you can feel that when you can genuinely
feel that that you're making something
that's gonna actually touch at least one
human being
that's a good that's a good addiction to
get you know to feel like we matter so
think back to what was the most painful
moment of your life
you want to find your vision you want to
find your purpose what's the most
painful moment of your life when did you
struggle the most as a human when did
you feel the most worthless useless it
doesn't mean that you were suicidal
though maybe you were but also doesn't
mean that you're in depression you know
maybe you were but when did you just
feel the lowest I never had any Suicidal
Thoughts I don't think I was depressed
either but I felt really low
when was that moment for you what were
the worst days of your life and your
purpose is then to help other people who
are struggling with that very same thing
because you've made it through
and it it doesn't mean that you're done
growing and learning I'm I'm still
learning I'm still growing that's why I
still watch videos and make videos
because I'm I'm still learning and
that's great you want to climb you climb
forever you never want to stop
progressing and stop climbing that's the
whole idea you know beyond the mountain
there's more Mountains you want to you
want to climb forever swim forever play
the game forever there is no Finish Line
that's the best part of it and every
time you take another step you reach
back and you help somebody get to where
you're at
and so you've learned a lot of lessons
if you think about who you used to be go
back to that moment where you were
struggling the most and that person you
know for me it's probably sitting at my
business partner's dining room table
uh just frustrated
[Music]
lost tried everything nothing's working
how am I here why did I say no to that
job why did I say yes to this what did I
just throw away everything my whole life
you know it'd be overly dramatic but
that's what was going through my mind
is what I was actually thinking so I had
it had you know what could I what would
I go back and tell that Evan so for you
what was the most painful moment in your
life imagine a picture it see yourself
there who are you with where are you you
know what's the setting around you and
imagine you can go back and talk to that
person younger you you had 15 minutes
with that person what would you say you
could help that person
you don't have to be Simon sinek or Tony
Robbins or Oprah Winfrey whoever you can
go back and help younger you
can give them some advice and in fact
younger you would probably listen to you
a lot more than they would listen to me
or Simon sinek or Tony Robbins Oprah
Winfrey or whoever because you've gone
through it they know who you are they
know that you understand them
and so they need your help
and that's that's what you create
whether it's making YouTube videos
whether it's some product or service
that you end up selling whether it's
joining some other organization who has
a similar Vision that you're going to
tie yourself to
but that's what you want to do that will
make your life meaningful that will make
you feel valuable that'll make you feel
connected to the thing that you're
waking up every day doing I think
ultimately that's what makes people
happy
and so your vision comes from your
purpose your purpose comes from your
pain
and if you felt like you're reaching
back and touching younger you and
helping make sure that other people
don't have to struggle and suffer as
much as you did
[Music]
that's the answer
the fulfillness happiness money and most
importantly
feeling like you are proud of yourself
and that you matter
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
when are you at your best I'm at my best
when I'm around people who believe what
I believe I know it seems silly but um
I try very very hard to sort of Stack
the deck you know to put myself in a
position of strength
um so for example you know somebody
asked me just yesterday have you ever
had sort of a bad you know engagement I
was thinking myself I'm like not really
but it's not because I'm some sort of
sort of Genius when he's saying anything
like that it's because I stack the deck
it's because I want to be there I want
to be around people who want me there in
other words if I'm somebody's 10th
choice and like you know I'll probably
turn it down
um whereas if I'm their first choice
they really want me there and so I'm I'm
more likely to have a good engagement
they're supportive of me I'm supportive
of them and so
um yeah I'm at my best when I when I
stacked the deck when I choose to be in
an environment where my strengths are
are there I spoke at an education Summit
for Microsoft I also spoke at an
education Summit for Apple
that's education for Mike at the
education Summit for Microsoft I would
say that 70 of the executives spent
about 70 percent of their presentations
talking about how to beat Apple
at the Apple education Summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their presentations
talking about how to help teachers teach
and how to help students learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite and the other one
is playing infinite get switch one gets
frustrated
so at the end of my talk at Microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
Zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you
this thing was spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology I'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular I absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and it didn't work on iTunes
which is a different problem so I
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my God it was elegant
so I'm sitting in the back of a taxi
with a very senior Apple executive sort
of employee number 12 kind of guy and
you know I like to stir pots so I turned
him I said you know
Microsoft gave me their new Zoom
and it is so much better than your iPod
Touch
and he turned to me and he said
I have no doubt
Conversation Over
the infinite
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse the goal isn't to
be the best every day the goal isn't to
out to outdo your competition every day
that's a finite construction if I had
said to Microsoft I've got the new iPod
touch and it's so much better than your
Zoom they would have said can we see it
what does it do react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play to be better than
themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today than it was yesterday
how can we create a product this week
that's better than the product we
created last week we also have to play
the infinite game it's not about being
ranked number one it's not about having
more followers on Twitter than your
friends it's not about outdoing anyone
it's about how to outdo yourself
it's not about selling more books or
getting more Ted views than somebody
else it's about how to make sure that
the work that you're producing is better
than the work you produced before you
are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy
because the joy comes not from
comparison
but from advancement every decision we
make in our lives as individuals or as
organizations is a piece of
communication it's our way of saying
something about who we are and what we
believe this is why authenticity matters
this is why you have to say and do the
things you actually believe because the
things you say and do are symbols of Who
You Are and we look for those symbols so
we can find people who believe what we
believe our very survival depends on it
so if you're putting out false symbols
you will attract people to those symbols
but you won't be able to form trust with
them this is what Tiger Woods did to us
he lied
he lied he told us what he thought we
wanted to hear and it was great and we
were drawn to it and all of us who kind
of like that idea of the sort of the
good guy we're drawn to it until we
found out it was a lie
he could have been the bad boy of golf
he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great athletes of our day but he didn't
he chose to lie good luck forming trust
again tiger we don't believe you
we don't trust you
the goal of putting something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe what you believe if you go
to one of your friends and you say to
one of your friends
how would you like me to dress
so that you'll like me better
how would you want me to address you how
do you want me to speak so that you'll
like me more
right your friends are going to look and
be like what are you talking about you
know come on come on come on what should
I wear so that you'll find me more
appealing and how would you like me to
speak to you so that you'll like me more
and your friends are going to tell you
just be yourself
that's why I like you I don't just be
yourself now think about what we do in
Industry what do we do we do market
research and we go and we ask the
customers what kind of things the way we
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate ourselves what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things you'll like us more
it's just as ridiculous it's just as
ridiculous organizations should say and
do the things they actually believe and
they will attract people who believe
what they believe or they can choose to
lie and at the slightest hint that they
might be lying cynicism sets in and
people start saying I'm not sure I can
trust these guys because there's not a
lot of consistency in all the things
they say and do which means they can't
have a very strong belief set or they're
lying to me
and we call them into authentic the
entire process of asking other people
who we should be is inauthentic that's
hilarious to me all these positioning
studies we do are inherent we're going
to do a study to find out from people so
we can be more authentic that's
hilarious
say and do what you actually believe and
the symbols you put out there the things
you say and the things you do those red
hats are ways that people can find you
what you have the ability to do
as designers is create those symbols and
allow people to use those things to say
something about who they are work for
companies work for clients work for
people who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself
and your part is to put what they
believe into pictures and words and
symbols and Graphics so that other
people can use those things to say
something about who they are people put
Harley Davidson logos on their body to
say something about who they are
corporate logo
ain't no Proctor and gambles tattooed on
anybody's arm
because Harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo on there not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle they put that
tattoo there to tell you something about
themselves
do you ever see anybody with a with a
Mac laptop put a sticker over that
beautiful shining Apple ain't never
gonna happen
how will you know who I am
do you ever see anybody with a PC break
out the Windex to clean out their
computer
Mac people
have you ever seen a dirty Mac
doesn't exist
does not exist why because it's who I am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear in what they
believe and they're disciplined in how
they do it and they're consistent in
what they do and everything they say and
everything they do serves as a symbol of
the set of values and beliefs we use
those symbols to say something about Who
We Are
we surround ourselves with the people
and the products and the brands that say
something about Who We Are
and when we can find the people who
believe what we believe we're weirdly
drawn to them
because our very survival
depends on it
we need it
and so the more you can give of yourself
the more you can give of what you
believe the more you can discipline with
discipline say and do the things you
actually believe strange things start to
happen now what are your thoughts and
what's your approach on finding and
building upon Passions
passion is not an actionable word it's
correct you know that those who do the
things that they're passionate about do
better but it's not helpful advice
um and so the question is where does
passion come from
Um passion is a result passion is an
energy passion is the feeling you have
when you're engaged in something that
you love passion is the feeling you have
that you would probably do this for free
you know and you can't believe somebody
pays you to do it you know and I think
we mistake that passion is something we
do in our private lives but it shouldn't
be done you know in our careers for
example and I'm a firm believer that you
are who you are and anybody who says I'm
Different at home than I am at work and
one of those two places you're lying and
the goal is to make everything you do in
home and at work something that you have
excitement to do so how do you find the
things that you're excited to do well
it's actually easier than you think what
are the things that you love to do what
are the things that you would do for
free you know how can you recreate that
feeling and and be paid for it so what
are the things that I do on the weekend
right I love
um I'm very involved in the art world I
love to go to museums and galleries but
I love to go see dance and performances
because I want to see how others are are
interpreting the world so that inspires
me new ideas new thoughts new ways
looking at the world are things that
interest me privately and I seek it out
and pay money for it right so does that
mean I have to have a career in the Arts
no it means I have to have a career
where new ideas are explored where
people are experimenting and trying
things out and I have to explore new
ideas and try things out and I'm just as
excited to go to work every day as I am
to you know go do something on a
Saturday night and so the idea of
finding your passion is ironically
simple because you should be doing stuff
that you enjoy sometimes
what is the stuff that you enjoy and
then what is the stuff that you love who
are the people that you love and what
are those what they all have in common
Nelson Mandela is
a particularly special case study in the
leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings
and he remembers two things when his
father would meet with other Elders one
they would always sit in a circle
and two
his father was always the last to speak
you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen I would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak
I see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be decent
leaders will walk into a room and say
here's the problem here's what I think
but I'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard it
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed
and two you get the benefit of hearing
what everybody else has to think before
you render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself if you agree with
somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know simply sit there take it all in and
the only thing you're allowed to do is
ask questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying
and at the end you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not
practice being the last to speak that's
what Nelson Mandela did how do you
develop self-confidence we're kind of
going off here now but I'm this is a
topic I'm really passionate about right
now I believe uh self-doubt is one of
the biggest Killers to anyone's Dreams
yeah so how does someone develop
self-confidence and sustain it with the
ever going changes and stresses and
uncertainties that always come up once
you reach a certain level there's a new
uncertainty yeah
so I think it's ironic that we call it
self-confidence
because I don't for one think it comes
from the inside
I think our self-confidence comes from
the outside
right that's the wrong way of going
about it or you think that's where it
comes from in general
that we are being misdirected by the
name
when we say build your self-confidence
that's the instruction is saying go
inside
look inside oneself but I think that's I
think that's I think that's a false
Direction children aren't born
self-confident
their confidence is built from their
parents and their friends and their
teachers
where they're rewarded when they do well
and they're pushed when they fail
when they can do better simply you know
we know this that simply telling kids
that they're great all the time actually
doesn't build self-confidence actually
does the total opposite right right
um and I for one I can tell you my in my
own experience my own self-confidence
um uh a hundred percent comes from the
relationships that I have
um it's not some deep internal fortitude
you know a world famous trapeze artist
is not going to try a brand new
death-defying act for the first time
without a net
so it's the people in my life
um it's it's when when I do doubt myself
that somebody says you got this
when somebody says
I believe in you when somebody says no
matter what happens whether it succeeds
or fails I'm going to be by your side
that's when I have the confidence to do
difficult things wow right I don't have
some natural battery that I that just
right you know that that to me is
bravado yeah I don't know about
self-confidence you know you know
being a huge risk taker is not an
indication of self-confidence to me you
know jumping out of a plane and jumping
over plane with a parachute are two
different things right right
um
um to me self-confidence is measured and
there should be a degree of of of Doubt
um but but I I think true
self-confidence belief in oneself and
belief in one's cause you know I could
not do the things that I'm doing and I
would not have the strength
um to have made the sacrifices that I've
made or continue to wake up on a daily
basis to drive to spread this message
um if I were alone and so when we talk
about building one self-confidence I
think the mistake that we make is that
we look inside I think the reality is
when we're trying to build our
self-confidence we should be looking to
our friends we should be nursing our
relationships when I'm looking to build
my self-confidence the question is who
around me do I need to take care of you
know the way we bit our self-confidence
is by helping somebody else build theirs
right it's an act of we will build our
confidence with an active service what
are your thoughts around courage how do
people get the courage to to play the
long game to not the long game it's the
infinite game it was a long game could
be five years right true yeah this is
forever
uh how do people build that everything
that we're talking about in the infinite
game is really really really really
really hard
it is so much easier to build a company
based on short-term Ambitions than it is
an infinite cause it just is right it's
also fun right until it's not
um less inspiring but sometimes
sometimes fun right hitting a goal feels
good right
um it's much easier to just hire and
fire people frequently higher fast Fire
fast as to hiring slowly and and firing
slowly because we we try and take care
of our people as best we can it's just
it's hard to build teams all of that
stuff we talked about leadership like
what am I supposed to do to build a
trusting team well I wish I could give
you a list of five things it's really
really hard to be a parent
it's much easier to be an uncle or an
aunt or not have kids right it's hard
right so why do it you know it's fun and
and exciting to be to try and beat our
competitors you know but to to have to
face our own weaknesses every day oh
that's exhausting you know existential
flexibility I'd rather not I just would
rather not you know so so the reason
this takes courage to completely change
our mindset a about the game that we're
actually players in
um and how we want to approach these
things and do we want to shift our
mindset and our organizations to prepare
for the infinite game to be organized
for the infinite game it takes courage
because we're going to be swimming
Upstream in a world that is very finite
driven you know the pressures on us are
overwhelming from Wall Street or our own
egos or from internal incentive
structures or our bosses whatever it is
the pressures are overwhelming for us to
play the finite game
and so how do you stand up to massive
external pressure courage
and courage is something that comes from
relationships you know it's external a a
world famous trapeze artist would never
attempt a brand new death-defying act
for the first time without a net
they would never do it so why do we
think that we could do something
difficult without external support too
um I've had the opportunity to meet real
heroes people who've risked their lives
to save the lives of others with the
belief that they were going to die
and they didn't and when I asked why did
you do it they all say something similar
which is they would have done it for me
it's external and so we have to have we
have to take the time to Foster and take
care of people around us to nurture our
relationships because when we're going
to be doing something difficult when
we're going to be swimming Upstream when
we're going to be innovating and and and
and and doing something different there
are days we're going to doubt ourselves
there are days we're going to get
knocked on our ass there are days that
storms are going to rise and we have to
have people who say I got you back
you need to do this
we need you the world needs this keep
going I believe in you you know
um and so courage courage comes from
from not only our willingness to do that
for others but then their willingness to
do it for us and we commit ourselves to
a just cause and we're willing to to do
those things then
you know the great thing is we take a
lot of people with us and change the
world for the better and isn't that sort
of the the point of an infinite life to
leave this world in better shape than we
found it to leave the companies that we
work for in better shape than when we
started to leave our families stronger
and better capable than than what they
can do without us you know isn't isn't
that what it means to live an infinite
life that we can live literally live on
beyond our own lives we take
accountability away from people and we
don't even realize it yeah so we're
actually destroying people's confidence
or ability to make decisions because we
keep answering their questions or making
decisions for them I had a boss many
years ago one of the best leaders I ever
had Peter and DiMaggio and
um he wouldn't answer a single question
I asked it drove me absolutely nuts hey
Peter you know what should I do well
what do you think we should do well I
I'm I think we should do this he goes
well you should give that a try then you
know or he would just ask me questions
he goes well have you considered this I
went no it goes well maybe think about
that you know but he would never tell me
the answer he'd always tell me the
parameters
um what he told me was self-reliance it
was the most valuable lesson I probably
ever ever learned
um very often you know somebody will
come and say you know should we go with
blue or green
I'll go with green well we just answered
the question once I go with the one you
think we should go with
what should we do here make the decision
you think is the right decision to make
you know and then let them make the
decision and when we give people
accountability the amazing thing is they
rise to it yeah but we keep taking the
accountability because we keep answering
all the questions so there's a very easy
lesson for everyone here is
um stop replying to all the emails that
you're getting while you're away
right like I know what happens you know
in every break or
right now uh you know there's an email
that says you know should we go with
this one or that one and you're replying
and in every break you're going to reply
to all your emails and you tell people
your opinion of what you think they
should do versus saying I'm going away
for a few days for this conference so I
can learn to be a better leader
um hold down the fort while I'm away
if there's an emergency figure it out
you know
um or only call me if you absolutely do
not know the answer
um and stop replying to all the emails
and they now have to work you're giving
away uh responsibility one of the
reasons they don't take responsibilities
because they don't give it to them heck
man I disagreed with my own ideas you
know I've been
I've been and yeah you're kind of like
falls apart they're just like okay yeah
I kind of screwed the pooch in that one
yeah but I take accountability yeah you
know or we find in the middle somebody
goes hey if we do this we can probably
be more successful and we pivot there's
there has to be at the decision-making
ranks there has to be a humility that
the ideas don't always have to come from
me right Bob Gaylor the fifth chief
Master Sergeant of the Air Force is the
best definition of humility I've ever
heard he said don't confuse humility
with meekness
humility is being open to the ideas of
others so you know it's not about like
oh it Shucks that's not humility you
know you and I know some remarkable
leaders people of great power and
authority and they have huge egos yes
you know they know they're good and they
don't mind talking about how good they
are but when somebody says hey I got an
idea they lean in like they're little
kids they go let's hear it you know I'm
looking at some of the photographs on
your wall and some of the folks that I
know here they have an insatiable
curiosity for ideas and even though
they're unbelievably accomplished if you
have something to share with them they
want to talk about it they want they
want to hear about it that's humiliating
to me you know so it's not this you know
it's not me it's you know
self-confidence is a good thing thinking
you're better than everyone else that's
unhealthy oh that's good yeah you know
thinking you're good is healthy thinking
you're better than others is unhealthy
one thing make them work together
um uh I shared incentives is also a part
of thing usually all we do is give
individual incentives which means we're
only incentivizing Behavior to work
individually
um
uh and by the way incentives don't
always have to be Financial it can be
just recognition and reward you know
catch people doing things right so when
you see people helping each other and
sharing call it out publicly you know
complement publicly criticize privately
um uh in front of the rest of the team
um give people promotions when there's a
behavior that you want to promote like
like teaming
um but also ask people to solve problems
together and and thank them together and
if one person comes to you and complains
I'm doing all the work you say well why
don't you find out what maybe they're
struggling maybe they're like we have to
push push back
um uh and also I think the most
important thing is leading by example
um asking for help I mean when the
leader acts like they know everything
and they have all the answers then all
it's doing is telling everybody else you
better know everything and have all the
answers because that's how you're going
to get ahead here and so I think one of
the most difficult things for anybody in
a leadership position to get comfortable
with is is saying I don't know or I need
help or can somebody help me or can you
do this with me
um I love working I love teaming with
folks on on my team it doesn't matter
what the rank structure is bringing
someone Junior let's work together
um even if all they're doing is poking
holes you know do you think this is good
no I think it can be better okay let me
try again
um so I think I think demonstrating the
behavior that we want is a big part of
it there are five practices in order to
lead uh with an infinite mindset
um you have to have a just cause
you have to have trusting teams you have
to have a worthy rival you have to have
a capacity for existential flexibility
and you have to have the courage to lead
so just cause we have to give our people
something to advance a cause so just
that they would be willing to sacrifice
their interests in order to do so in
other words turn down a better paying
job or frequent business trips or
working late hours and though I may not
like those things I do them because it
feels worth it because I believe in what
I'm a part of here because I feel that
I'm helping Advance because there's no
achieving in the infinite game the goal
is not final achievement the goal is
advancing to progress in the infinite
game and to have that vision of an
idealized state of the world that all
men are created equal right it's an
ideal that a nation is striving towards
that will never actually get there but
will die trying that's the point and we
can offer people the same thing inside
an organization in fact we have to to
give them something to advance now how
is this different from the why a why
comes from the past it is an origin
story every single one of us has our own
unique why it is our Birthright it comes
from the sum total of how we were raised
as kids it is objective you have one and
you have one for the rest of your life
the only one right and the rest of our
lives are about making the decisions
that help us uh keep in balance with our
why a just cause doesn't come from the
past it just causes about the future
it's about where we're going right you
can have multiple just causes you can
have one professionally you can have one
personally you can have one for your
family you can have one for your church
and we're involved in all of these
there's massive pressure put on people
especially young people too what's your
vision well we're not all Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates we're not all Visionaries we
don't have to have a vision but we do
have to find a vision that we can find
someone else's vision and we are so
compelled by it that we want to make it
our own that's what it means to go work
for a company with a Visionary leader
that we believe in that Vision so
clearly that we take their vision and we
make it our own and we will happily
contribute our work our effort in order
to advance what is now my vision right
Martin Luther King had a vision he stood
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial and
told us his vision but his vision became
our vision so I may not have come up
with that Vision but I found it and I'd
like to devote time and energy to help
Advance it even Beyond him there's a
whole industry around I think work-life
balance yes yeah it's like there's a
massive industry that's just trying to
teach this and help people with
work-life balance yeah the problem it
seems like it's failing Street animals
treating a symptom isn't it you know
it's
you know it's like so many things in our
life you see so here's the bad analogy
um so we buy running sneakers and they
have really thick you know this yeah
they have really thick heels tons of
padding in the heel right but that's
because people don't know how to run
right because we land with our heel
which is bad for our joints you know
you're not supposed to have an extended
knee yeah all of it you're supposed to
be a toe planter where your knees are
always bent I mean you know all this
yeah so instead of teaching people how
to run
what we do is we just build shoes with
more padding in the heel
and treat the symptom rather than the
Cause right and uh I think it's it's the
same thing you know uh uh we we treat
symptoms instead of the cause
so so the work-life balance thing what
we're doing is instead of instead of
changing businesses instead of changing
the way a business operates and changing
the way in which we teach leaders to
operate with an infinite mindset so that
we more naturally have work-life balance
and let's be Crystal Clear work-life
balance means you know doing more yoga
does not create work-life balance right
that's the that's the shoe that's the
cushion on the shoe right yeah
the imbalances I feel safe at home I
don't feel safe at work that's the
imbalance and no amount of yoga or
vacation time
is gonna fix that what fixes that
work-life imbalance is better quality
leadership in our businesses
and then what you'll find is the balance
but instead what we do is we have an
entire industry that's treating the
symptom that's putting that's putting
cushion on the shoe to to make us feel
kinda for an hour right that I've
achieved balance you know
but it's just for an hour and you know
we literally Market you know companies
Market themselves as helping provide you
work-life balance unless you're teaching
leaders to the people who are my bosses
then you are not helping me achieve work
like mountains you're helping me numb
the pain you have me cushion the blow we
all carry a narrative
um someone's lazy
um someone's stupid
someone doesn't care
someone's only in it for themselves
these are narratives that we carry and
the problem is when we evaluate their
behavior through our narrative we it'll
become it will become self-reinforcing
we will see the things that reinforce
our narrative
and the problem is then we'll treat them
that way if we've decided someone's lazy
we're going to treat them as lazy
so there's a great exercise to do which
is literally take out a piece of paper
and when we're struggling with someone
to think what are the 20 other things
that could be going on in their life so
yeah number one they're lazy possible
it's absolutely possible number two
they're having trouble in their marriage
uh number three their
um things have gone wrong and they and
they don't know how to ask for help
number four they're still struggling
with the trauma of covid number five
their kids are flunking out of school
like all of a sudden we realize there's
a lot of other reasons that could
explain their behavior and we will then
treat them accordingly we will treat
them with greater empathy you know
instead of walking to someone's
classroom and saying what the hell
you're you know your performance is
still down I've had this conversation
with you before you got to get your
performance up or I don't know what's
going to happen
or you can walk into their classroom and
say your performance is down we've had
this conversation before are you okay
I'm worried about you we we they have a
problem but they aren't necessarily the
problem and even if ultimately it does
become that they're a bad fit the
culture they're still they are still not
the problem they still are just a bad
fit for the culture they have a problem
we can help them solve that problem by
going to help them relocate to a
different School District where they're
going to be so much happier we're going
to be so much happier everybody gets to
be so much happier so the other story I
was thinking of is the story of Alan
Mullally
when he took over Ford
um Ford is losing money hand over fist
in other words performance was in
Decline and when he sat down with his
most senior Executives and he asked for
a report on how their divisions were
going regular green every single one of
them delivered PowerPoints with all
green slides
and he said at the end of the meeting
how can everything be green if we're
losing billions of dollars
and they just sat there and he had
another meeting same thing all green and
he said the same thing how can
everything be green if we're losing
billions of dollars the problem was the
previous leader if you delivered a red
slide you got fired
and so there is no way that anybody was
going to tell the truth
because their job depended on it
and so one executive took the risk to
turn one slide red
and malali said thank you for the the
the the the visibility that's great
transparency now how can we all help him
fix that problem he has a problem he is
not the problem all the other Executives
thought he was going to get fired
turns out he wasn't and slowly but
surely everybody including leadership
could finally get a clear and
transparent view of what was actually
going on in their organization and they
worked together to solve the problems if
somebody was struggling people said how
can we help you rather than I'm fine
you're the one that's screwing
everything up so it's a great way to
think about it we come to work feeling
uncomfortable that some of the decisions
that are being made
don't benefit the good of the employee
that it really benefits this this
artificial constituency that we call the
shareholder which is really just a bunch
bunch of institutional investors there's
this shareholder myth because there's
been a steady decline of the middle
class being involved in the stock market
for years and the whole point of the
stock market was that we all get to
share in the wealth that we helped build
because it's on the back of Average Joe
employees that produce the great wealth
in the nation and the whole point of the
stock market The Genius of the modern
day Corporation The Genius of the public
company was that we all get to share in
the wealth that we're helping produce
unfortunately over the course of the 80s
and 90s we've seen systems produced
where we're seeing the general
population the middle class actually be
less included in in that success and the
reason I wrote the infinite game was
because I myself got tired of being told
by people in positions of Authority or
people of extreme wealth that I was
naive that I don't under understand how
business business works and for many
years I believed them I thought maybe I
am the dumb one right we all kind of
feel that because they have the power
they have the authority they have the
money they know more than we do
but we still go to work and feel
uncomfortable and it turns out that that
discomfort that gut feeling that says
that there's something wrong here turns
out that the majority actually knows
something
and to me this is a World is Flat moment
that that the the the the people who've
learned to game the system that this
discomfort that we feel we're we
actually are right like they actually
don't understand the game they're in
business is an infinite game and when
you play with a finite mindset lots of
people suffer including the companies
that they themselves are trying to build
that's the great irony the great irony
is the way you build great companies is
with an infinite mindset the way you
build great companies is by prioritizing
people before profit the way you build
great companies is will before resources
um both both things important but there
has to be this General leaning where we
can feel when we come to work and feel
like we're part of something bigger than
ourselves where we feel that our work
and our effort is worth more than simply
the money we make we are designed to
take care of each other as social
animals it is in our biology that we
will take care of each other this is why
it feels so good when some somebody does
something really nice for us with no
expectation of anything in return we've
all had the experience where somebody
does something nice and you're like oh
my God thank you and then they put their
hand out you're like oh it kind of like
ruins the whole experience completely it
ruins it but when they just do it and
they're like no no and you're like
please like no no it's my pleasure yeah
you know not only does our esteem for
them go up but it just it feels good
likewise it feels good when we do
something for someone else with no
expectation of anything in return when
we give our time and our energy money
actually doesn't work believe it or not
like if I told you I gave 500 to charity
this morning you'd be like okay that's
great Simon but if I told you that last
weekend I gave up my Saturday and went
to Painted schools in the inner city
you'd be like nice that's really awesome
now the value of my labor was worth a
lot less than 500 and that's the point
right that's the point which is
um we were designed to take care of each
other and there's a chemical called
oxytocin which is the chemical
responsible for our feelings of love and
friendship and Trust when you look at
somebody you adore and you go like this
that's oxytocin when somebody touches
you and says oh my God it's so good to
see you touch creates oxytocin so good
to see you yeah you know it actually
makes us feel closer to each other you
know
when oxytocin is released in our bodies
not only does it make us feel good not
only does it boost our immune systems
but the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies it actually makes us more
generous because the human body is
trying to get us to look after each
other and it gets even better than that
the person who does the act of
generosity giving of time or energy
without expectation of anything in
return they get a shot of oxytocin the
person on the receiving end gets a shot
of oxytocin
and even witnessing an act of generosity
or kindness releases oxytocin it feels
good to see somebody do something nice
and the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies as I said means we're more likely
to do something nice for somebody this
is the biology of pay it forwards it's
the human body's desperate attempt to
get us to look after each other
and so when we create environments where
we allow that to flow it does naturally
it just takes care of itself it's just
biology
um when we create environments where we
restrict that it actually does the
opposite it releases a chemical cortisol
which is the feeling of stress and
anxiety cortisol actually inhibits
oxytocin which means if we work in a
poorly LED organization not only do we
have high stress but we actually it the
it actually inhibits empathy and in
other words I'm less likely to even want
to care about at somebody because of the
poor leadership and the poor environment
that's been provided for me to work in
right and the more cortisol we have in
our bodies stress goes up anxiety goes
up it affects our immune systems happy
people live longer happy people have
lower rates of cancer diabetes and heart
disease which means when you're in a
position of leadership you're actually
medically responsible for the lives of
these people get the environment right
they will live longer they will suffer
lower cases of disease and they will
probably have happier families because
of it whereas if you're a bad leader
over the course of time you're actually
killing the people working with you our
jobs are actually killing us the
thinking of Milton Friedman the the
1970s Economist has really dominated
sort of business Theory today he
theorized that the responsibility of
business this is his definition the
responsibility of business is to
maximize profit within the bounds of the
law right what about ethics you know
like a a pharmaceutical company that
raises the price on essential drug 200
300 500 800 percent it's not illegal it
is unethical right it makes us
uncomfortable and yet the law is not
broken that's not a good enough standard
to run a business
um and it was his thinking that gave
rise to the theory of shareholders
Supremacy which was a theory proposed in
the late 1970s where
um we prioritize the once needs and
desires of a shareholder over the needs
of the customer or the employee which is
like a coach who's trying to build a
great team by doing what the fans want
versus what the players need right
that's basically shareholder Supremacy
and as I said it was just a theory
proposed in late 1970 that was
popularized during the boom years of the
80s and 90s Mass layoffs where we use
the livelihoods of human beings to meet
arbitrary projections on an annualized
basis at the end of the year did not
exist did not exist as a standard
business practice prior to the 1980s did
not exist it was popularized doing
during the 80s and 90s the dismantling
of glass-steagall which was an Act
passed after the Great Depression to
prevent another Great Depression from
happening and by the way was extremely
effective between the dismantling of the
glass-steagall in the 80s and 90s and
the Great Depression there were a total
of zero stock market crashes since then
dismantling all in the name of corporate
profit we've had three we had uh the.com
Boom Black Monday in 2008.
in other words when we play simply with
a finite mindset we actually do
long-term damage to our own system
that's supposed to benefit all of us
um and and and and I find that upsetting
um we've seen the rise of of of of
Milton's uh of Friedman's thinking
rather
um and like I said his theories dominate
business today and we feel it not only
have we had those those stock market
crashes but anybody who goes to work
today there's a general feeling of
unease you know especially if you work
for a company that Embraces annual or
even quarterly layoffs to meet arbitrary
projections keep in mind a lot of the
companies that employ uh Mass layoffs
are profitable just not as profitable as
they would like it's not like they're
losing money and they had to do this to
save this sinking ship that's something
completely different these are highly
profitable companies that missed a
projection and so they laid people off
so they could meet that projection
there's something fundamentally wrong
with that and we know it because we feel
it at work we see this decline of trust
we are not loyal to our companies
anymore why would we be they're not
loyal to us and leader set the tone so
when companies are loyal to us we will
give loyalty back to them when they're
not loyal to us why would we be loyal to
them I'm tired of of CEOs telling me
that you know Millennials these days
don't stick around very long well why
would they if you don't offer them any
kind of loyalty uh back and it's not for
the people to prove to you that they're
loyal it's the other way around we make
time for the things that matter to us
yeah
um and and of course of course I have
regrets but but regrets is not I
wouldn't use the word regret of course
there are things that I missed
and but I made a choice and I'm very
happy with that choice and I stand by
that choice because not only have I had
the opportunity the amazing experience
to spread this message and see it
actually grow and be bigger than me but
I'm it's I've I've had the opportunity
to live an absolutely Surreal Life
because of it my life profoundly changed
course and I cannot I can't it's not
fair to compare those things they're not
easy yeah you know you know everybody
with straight hair one's curly hair
anywhere with a curly one straight hair
you know that once before I mean I know
people who have
the stability in the home life and the
families and look at my life and be like
oh my God I wish I had that and you look
at my life and I'm bouncing all around
and I mean it's the answer is I'm really
grateful for the life that I live so no
regret is not the word that I would use
but there was a price there's a price
that it cost that I that I took
willingly there are two currencies in
the infinite game will and resources
resources is money you need money to
stay in the game but you need the will
of the people as well and um the problem
is is that when we organize to win that
means the score is more important than
the inspiration of motivation than
people have to to give their Blood Sweat
and Tears and when we prioritize
resources before will that's a problem
I've never met a CEO that doesn't
believe their people are important the
problem is where on the priority list
you know you've been to any number of uh
presentations where they put their
priorities on the wall you know number
one growth number two shareholder value
number three our customer number for our
employees there it is yeah I do care
about our people and the reality is as
social animals we want to work for and
we're willing to give our Blood Sweat
and Tears to leaders who understand that
the balance of those two essential
currencies the balance of those two
things is Will has to come before
resources and that doesn't mean 90 10
when I talk about putting people before
profit you know people freak out which
is ridiculous you need fuel for the car
to go money is fuel for the organization
of course even if there's a leaning it's
5149 there has to be a slight leaning
towards people because there will always
be decisions that a company has to make
in which those two cannot uh both be
supplied and one will have to be
sacrificed the question the question is
which will you always prioritize
um let me give you a hypothetical
example to make my point two CEOs the
first CEO says our number one priority
is growth and of course our people are
important because if we take care of our
people we will meet and exceed our
financial goals
second CEO says our number one priority
is our people and if we take care of our
people we will always meet and exceed
our financial goals which one would you
rather work for I don't want the party I
mean it's obvious right it's obvious
um so this is what it means to
prioritize Willow resources it has of
course of course uh Money Matters
um but the people matter more working at
a at a at a hard job working for a bad
bus can sometimes be one of the greatest
educations ever so the question is can
we can you change your mindset
instead of waking up in the morning
going oh I can't do this again but
rather view it as University you know
you're getting a master's degree in
leadership and you may be learning
everything how not to do things and you
to wake up in the room and be like what
am I going to learn today
early on in my career I had I had a
really bad boss who believed that she
could get the most out of us by berating
us and and she she told me once that I
had one of my reviews and she said you
have no talent and I was like nothing
and she was like nothing this was her
way of I guess motivating me
um but I had such a good attitude about
it for a couple of reasons one because I
knew I knew what I was up against every
day and instead of taking it personally
I viewed it as as my education of how
not to lead and I literally would file
this stuff all the way and use it
someday I get to use it now
um and also
misery loves company you know I had
fantastic a fantastic relationship with
my team we looked after each other
because we all had this this oppressive
bus we would compare the advice that we
got in our in our uh in our little
career building sessions
um and uh and we took care of each other
and so we had a responsibility to each
other and that's where we cut our teeth
on being leaders and it actually made
the job wonderful yes there were days
that were oppressive yes there were days
that I hated yes there are days I want
to like pull my hair out and just quit
but it's because of the team that I had
that we looked after each other and the
mindset of learning every day that I
that I made the most of it so I think
mindset is a huge huge huge part of
actually getting some joy out of a out
of a difficult job this is the practice
of empathy that if we're struggling to
communicate to someone if it's
struggling to help someone be at their
natural best I'm tired of people saying
to me how do I get the best out of my
people really that's what you want
they're like a towel you just ring them
how can I get the most out of them
no how do I help my people be at their
natural best
right we're not asking these questions
we are not practicing empathy we have to
start by practicing empathy and relate
to what they may be going through and it
will profoundly change the decisions we
make it will profoundly change the way
we see the world because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
you want another amazing Simon silent
clip check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there